what do you think about what's going on
with america last
couple years here politically where
you're in an industry that's
you you you guys i have friends in that
world and we talk but you know it's
walking on x shows a little bit in the
business you're in how has that affected
your business the last few years how has
it affected my business well i you know
i personally um
find all politicians to be liars
and so i don't i i there's no way for me
to get behind a political party simply
because i just don't trust any of them
um
in in my business i do know
that
ten years ago tennis years ago there was
a group called the friends of abe
abraham lincoln being the first
republican president
and
it was a very big group and they would
publish their their board and all the
members and it was a very open group and
as soon as trump came into office the
other side
got so crazy that this group was no
longer allowed to exist so it disbanded
and uh and and that to me
that makes me sad the the intolerance
for another perspective because i think
that for the most part individuals not
politicians but individuals have these
ideas of i perceive a problem and for
the most part everybody can agree that
whatever x is a problem
so then it's just about finding
solutions and i might have a different
idea about a solution than you have but
i don't think that we should be
waging war with each other over our
difference
of solving the same problem and
and that intolerance is is very
disappointing i used to go to meetings
with john voigt in la and
uh with a
man named fred and then a couple other
guys
owners of public storage and would go to
this the house in malibu and they would
have the most interesting conversations
but the way they would do it it wasn't
like the republicans
they would bring the campaign manager of
bill clinton and they would bring the
campaign manager of bush
two-hour conversations 40 of us in the
room and let me tell you
unfrickin believably entertaining yeah
and like you're learning right so when
the camera was off they they got along
it's it's almost like hey we're just the
two different teams let's just figure
out you know what my motives are you
know and i got to give up some stuff to
get with you but
you know going through john and you know
some of the other guys i mean obviously
we know who in hollywood is what side
and what not side but
some of them got ousted some of them
didn't some of them were bulletproof you
couldn't do [ __ ] to clint eastwood it's
like no you can't yeah yeah you can't do
[ __ ] stuff
yeah for sure there are a couple of them
gary sinise i think he can probably
be aligned with whatever he wants and
he's fine but i think for the rank and
file there became a thing where it's
like well we're just not going to say
anything we're not going to openly
support anything
i agree yeah i agree that sucks and
and is there anybody that's kind of like
because i saw did you see the article
with mark wahlberg what he announced
yesterday if you want to pull up mark
wahlberg uh the movie he did the father
stew with mel gibson
and mel gives someone the greatest
actors of all time but he came out and
he said something yesterday about the
fact that he's inspired yeah said mark
walter explains how mel gibson inspired
him to spend millions and millions of
his own money on father stew
and not only that this story goes
further he says
i feel at this phase of my life i'm i'm
getting a calling can you make is this
yesterday's article or two days ago this
is two days ago oh it's it's uh it's
yesterday the article i wrote was
yesterday it's very recent go back a
little bit anyway so he himself
you see him as a pretty reasonable guy
reveals mark by the way
mark wahlberg
you can click on that one
really you can't really see it it's not
so overt but that dude has evolved that
dude when i was young i i've known
mark for a long time i did a movie was
he an american history x or no no but i
did a movie with him called deepwater
horizon but i have known him for a long
time when we were kids like children
teenagers he was a bit of a mess he
wasn't maybe as much of a mess or as
overt of a mess as i was and and i i
don't think he had a real drug problem
but or did drugs at all i don't i don't
know about that but
he now
is a father he's married he's very
serious about his faith like he has
turned his life around really in a big
way a big way and he you know the movie
he did bro was it brothers what was the
name of the movie where the four brother
the
it's him yeah is it four brothers a
movie yeah exactly yeah so i and tyrese
i just say i just feel like that's him
the movie he played the story of mickey
not mickey ward is it mickey word where
the brother is a is it the fighter it's
called the fighter yeah you just look at
him you're like i don't think you're
acting bro i just believe you you know i
just think you're being you like
denzel's not acting to me denzel is just
himself you know and he's got one role
that he crushes it right you don't see
him being able to do
you know but he sticks to this one role
that he crushes because i don't think
he's acting but to see a guy like him uh
he just showed me an article here from
people magazine where he says uh uh you
know he's
feeling like there's a
calling this is god choosing me it was
one of the yeah god choosing me
tyler it's on slack i don't see it on
slack check yesterday anyway so you're
seeing you're seeing some of that taking
place because
i believe uh uh the power of uh right
there so mark wahlberg says he spent
millions on faith-based movies this is
god choosing me to make it okay go up a
little bit to see what else he says
they're making a little bit bigger uh
50-year-old angel manager right now
sorry german father still male gibson
resembles the director
let's just say i put millions and
millions of dollars into the film and
then incurring
other costs because we went over
schedule and production and there were
clearances for the music
uh uh
said well we're adding that the few
friends who believed in the project also
invested in wahlberg said he prayed
every day about getting this film made i
cannot take credit for the movie success
because this is god choosing me to make
this film he knows finally i get to
utilize all the talents and gifts that
have been bestowed upon me for his
greater good and serve my part in his
big picture so
you're seeing some of that this is i
believe you know you know
one time
one of my mentors dudley gives a speech
he said there's seven mountains to climb
you know military you know you got
business you got church you got all
these politics and then he says
entertainment he says the toughest one
to climb to the top is entertainment but
entertainment is the one that you can
really have some mass influence right
whoever controls hollywood and movies
controls the masses i mean that's just
what there is to it if i want to
manipulate a mindset into anybody i'll
just make a movie out of it and put the
right actor spend 100 million dollars i
can get you to think well maybe that's
not that bad of an idea right
so but i don't think we have enough
competition on both sides like i think
vince vaughn was it where he went and he
sponsored he endorsed was it ron paul at
a libertarian event i don't know if you
remember that i don't know but i do know
that that whatever he did politically
probably had sort of an effect on him
yeah so oh you think
hollywood kind of excommunicated him
because he i don't know i don't know
about excommunicated he's still around
he's still doing movies but finn fong
was a massive movie star dude and meg
was not a massive movie
and i don't think he had a huge string
of failures no i what failure i mean i
do the guy has got everybody gets their
set of failures like you talked about
earlier if our show goes we literally
disappear uh but
but what what what what does it take in
that space
to get to a point of being untouchable
is it your own money because clint is
using his own money at this point of
course he's got some investors that come
in as well but it's majority of it is
his own money
also even think about this woody allen
woody allen still makes a movie every
year or
every other year or something like that
and he is basically
in dark blacked out like you don't hear
about the movies you don't see the
movies they're all just going to europe
or something like that but he still
manages to get them made it's it's all
funded out of another country or private
private investors or something like that
hollywood is not investing in woody
allen i don't know if there's anybody
that's
untouchable in hollywood no matt i mean
look at will smith i mean he would have
been a martial
harvey weinstein i mean but he's not he
doesn't have the name recognition that a
will smith does or even a mel gibson did
in the early 2000s there's a difference
harvey weinstein was a gangster he was
yes he was politically connected harvey
weinstein was behind the scenes yeah
untouchable but to the masses it's like
who's this that's why i don't there's
there there is a there is an example
there
that's different than vince vaughn and
then clint
and he got some of the other guys right
grump you know josh
i would put him there as well probably
if uh uh is it frant uh
is it a chris chris pratt chris pratt
right who played uh they're trying to
they're trying to get him too yeah
they're trying to get him to to get rid
of chris brack because he's he's
religious zach levi even zach levi
though
uh there's a big portion of hollywood or
the left which
does not approve of the church that
chris pratt goes to and so there is
constantly attempts to say like you
should not have until this guy
apologizes for his church or makes his
church better you should
not hire this guy are these the same
people that are trying to cancel if you
were part of the friends of abe are they
the same people that are trying to
cancel pratt are they saying people you
know by the way canceling vince vaughn
who are these people it could be two
people on twitter
i don't know who who it is but there is
a general sentiment
that uh if your church was ever not
super fond of gay people your church's
is
excommunicated and you can't be a part
of it so i know like ellen page has uh
elliot page has come out and talked
poorly about chris pratt and his church
which then leads to voices on twitter
anonymous voices on twitter yeah and and
it builds that way i don't know who all
of the people are but they're
the the culture of hollywood is very
um get in line or get out yeah i mean
not not tolerant of religious positions
not tolerant isn't there other irony
there that their whole thing is
inclusion
uh
tolerance but if you don't fit in fall
in line
i think any of that though even on the
right if it's if the idea is like
absolute free speech
then you know
what was the um the the satanic panic of
the 80s and 90s that was all a
right-wing fear of like you can't talk
about this stuff right like let's arrest
two live crew their language is bad i
think no matter what the group in power
wants to stay in power and they want uh
a homogeneous uh
dialogue so that there's no dissent
there's no taking that power away from
them yeah don't don't forget
we're not against rap we're not against
rappers but we are against those
thoughts
right so they wanted to kind of you know
the hip-hop all of that
so but here here's here's what you said
you said harvey weinstein and you said
will smith the difference with will
smith it's a self-inflicted he screwed
up holly was not canceling him he
canceled himself that's what he did
that's a big scrub which we can talk
about that but will smith
is a screw-up which is a lot deeper than
anything else but by the way i would my
preference would be
you do something that people are
offended by you have a very clear path
to redemption there should be some way
to make amends you come out and
apologize i don't know what it is but
there should be a way to go like
without being self-serving i screwed up
i'm really sorry that's not me because
will smith to me is like he was the he
was this i still think he's a sweetheart
and he had a bad one
he
but think about what we're saying here
right now we're actually putting harvey
freaking weinstein and will smith even
no no he's not i don't know i'm not
saying that i'm just saying the fact
that those two names are intertwined
because will smith slap chris rock i
don't think they're in the same country
no no they're not yeah that's my point
yeah but the fact that
harvey weinstein what he did was
disgusting and repugnant
and what will smith okay
can i make a can i make a
prediction i want to make a prediction
to you okay
so what what i think is happening is the
following so will is different story
harvested harvey is you know complete he
uses power to abuse and all that stuff
and eventually it was too late
vince is hey we don't agree with you he
is actually being affected by because
this guy goes from being one of you some
everywhere to and by the way that guy's
multi-dimensional he did like this one
psycho movie that you know maybe it was
psycho i don't know what movie he was in
where he's playing this freaking crazy
husband that's
capable of doing murder and all these
things then he goes and does wedding
crashers so he's so multi-talented if
you enjoyed this short clip click over
here to watch another short clip and if
you want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]
you